يستغيث بامريكا ارجوكم اجعلونا كاسرائيل
واشنطن تستجيب بالاستعداد لخطوه جديده
لطالما حذر منها فهل من رد روسيا عاجل
وحاسم والبحريه الروسيه تحرك اسلحتها
مصوبه اهدافا مهمه في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وقرابه خمسه الاف جندي اوكراني في مهب
الريح خلال اسبوع واحد فعن اي مجزره نتحدث
ورئيس الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه ينجو من
عشره محاولات اغتيال فهل تكون الحاديه عشر
هي الاخيره وكيف تعلن استعاده منطقه
استراتيجيه وتعيد بالمزيد والجزائر تستقبل
وحش المحيطات الروسي والعين ترمق احداث
النيجر والرئيس الفرنسي يعلن استعداده
للحرب في النيجر وبولندا تعلن حاله
الطوارئ وت المواطنين
نعم لقد كثرت المطالب الاوكرانيه والغرب
لا يستجيب على الدوام لكن هذه المره اعلنت
عن طلب هو الاخير امنه ان تحقق واشنطن هذا
الطلب فقد اعلن الرئيس الاوكراني
بان تحصل على ضمانات امنيه من الولايات
المتحده على الطراز الذي تم تقديمه
لاسرائيل وقال زيلينسكي مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه من المحتمل ان يكون
لدينا مثل النموذج الاسرائيلي حيث سيكون
هناك اسلحه وتكنولوجيا وتدريب وتمويل وما
الى ذلك الا ترون انه طلب مستحيل لان
تنفيذه قد يقود الى حرب اهليه فهل ترد
واشنطن بالمثل العربي حلم ابليس في الجنه
فقد اعلنها الامريكانو على الدوام لانهم
لن ينجروا الى ما يقود الى
نظيفا انه في تلك الحاله سنترك لمصيرنا
على حد تعبيره واشار الى انه من الممكن
الدفع باتجاه تجريد روسيا من السلاح في
القرن بالوسائل السياسيه في ظل الاوضاع
الراهنه فان ذلك من احلام اليقظه يا هذا
واسال حلفاءك الغربيين اما على ميدان
المعارك فتواصل الحرب لهيبها حيث اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان خسائر قوات قياف
في منطقه العمليه العسكريه لهذا الاسبوع
بلغت
4855 عسكريا حيث قتل
1490 جنديا اوكرانيا على محور دونيتسك فقط
يا لها من ارقام خياليه ولكن المصادر هي
من تتحدث هذا فيما اكد ممثل قسم
الاستخبارات بوزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
ان رئيس الاستخبارات العسكريه كيريل
بودانوف تعرض لاكثر من عشره محاولات خلال
السنوات العشر الماضيه لتعود الدفاع
الروسيه وتعلن ان بحريتها وجهت ضربه
الناجحه لمستودع يحتوي على اسلحه الطيران
والذخائر التابعه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه وحسب بيانات الوزاره الروسيه
فقد خسر الجيش الاوكراني نحو 50070 جنديا
على محاور القتال الاساسيه خلال 24 ساعه
ان ارقبهم المعتاده والعهده على المصدر
كما تشاهدون فها نحن نتصفحه امامكم في
الموقع الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه وكما هو
معتاد تستمر حرب الجو عبر المسيرات حيث
كانت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قد اعلنت عن
اسقاط طائرتين بدون طيار اوكرانيتين فوق
اراض شبه جزيره القرم مضيفه انها دمرت
مسيره اوكرانيه في ضواحي موسكو واثنتين
اخريين في مقاطعه بريانسيك الحدوديه مع
اوكرانيا بينما تم اغلاق مطاري
الدوليين في موسكو فتره وجيزه امام حركه
المسافرين الوزاره الروسيه افادت ايضا
بتدمير صاروخ اوكراني مجنح قباله سواحل
شبه جزيره القرم من جهتها اعلنت اوكرانيا
استعاده السيطره بالكامل على منطقه
روبوتين في جنوب شرق البلاد على خط
المواجهه في منطقه زابوريجيا وتحتل قريه
رباط موقعا استراتيجيا في مدينه ميلوتوبال
وقال الجيش الاوكراني انه يواصل التقدم
ببطء بعد اختراق خط الدفاع الروسي بالقرب
من روبوتين مؤكدا ان الهدف التالي للتحرير
هو قريه
وهنا ناتيكم بالمصدر فنحن لا ناتي بشيء من
عندنا
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه حررت منطقه روبوتين في جنوب
شرق البلاد وسط مسائل للتقدم جنوبا في
هجومها المضاده على القوات الروسيه الى
ذلك لقي شخصان مسرعهما في هجوم صاروخي
استهدف منشاه صناعيه في منطقه بولوتافا
وسط اوكرانيا
الباخمه هذه المره بعد تحرير منطقه
روبوتين في الجنوب والقوات الاوكرانيه
تعلن عن تحرير كيلو متر مربع ليبلغ اجمالي
المساحه الكليه التي حررت القوات
الاوكرانيه في محيط باخموت وبين هذا وذاك
نشرت القوات الاوكرانيه مشاهد تظهر حيله
ذكيه تتبعها قواتها لكشف الالغام وتفجيرها
خلال الهجوم المضاد جنوب البلاد حيث مثلت
تلك الالغام مشكله اساسيه تسببت ببطء
الهجوم العسكري الكبير واظهر الفيديو
استخدام المهندسين الاوكرانيين متفجرات
بلاستيكيه لتفجير الالغام الروسيه وذلك
بحسب هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه الاحداث والتطورات قالت الدفاع
الجزائريه في بيان ان الفرقات امير كوريا
734 التابعه لاسطول البحر الاسود الروسي
رست في الجزائر في اطار تجسيد برنامج
التعاون العسكري ثنائي بين البلدين وذكرت
ان هذا التوقف سيشهد تسطير عده نشاطات
ثقافيه ورياضيه لفائده طاقم السفينه حسب
البيان نفسه هل
تختم الروسيا في الحفاظ على امن حدودها
خصوصا مع تزايد احتمالات اقتراب التدخل
العسكري في النيجر دعونا نرى وبخصوص
النيجر اكد الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرو
ان بلاده ستواصل سياستها الحازمه بعدم
الاعتراف بالانقلابيين في النيجر ودعم
الرئيس المحتز محمد وقال ماكرون ان فرنسا
ودبلوماسيه هواجه مواقف صعبه بشكل خاص في
بعض البلدان في الاشهر الاخيره من السودان
الى النيجر مشيرا الى ان وجود فرنسا في
افريقيا لا يتعلق فقط بالتهديد الارهابي
وان الحل العسكري لا ينبغي ان يحل محل
السياسي اعلنت المتحدث باسم حرس الحدود
البولنديه انمي شاليسكا انه تم اخلاء مطار
الشوبان في وارسو بسبب قنبله يدويه كان
مواطن من جنوب افريقيا يحاول تهريبها من
بولندا واشارت الى انه بعد العثور على
القنبله تم اجلاء 400 شخص من المطار هذا
وجرى اعتقال الرجل وتم ارساله الى مكتب
المدعي العام
[موسيقى]